-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
You're here, you made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, today
is the one-year anniversary
of the January 6th riot
at the Capitol.
President Biden marked the day
with a speech,
and he really unloaded on Trump.
Listen to this.
-He's not just
a former president,
he's a defeated
former president.
Defeated by a margin of
over 7 million of your votes,
in a full and free and fair
election.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biden -- Biden
is not messing around there.
I know that vibe.
That's "high school principal
after a food fight" vibe.
[ Laughter ]
They just rub it in.
Biden was like,
"I would have DM'd you,
but I couldn't find you
on Twitter."
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Let's switch gears.
This is a fun story.
Pope Francis just held
his weekly general audience,
where he gets to
greet and meet people
and go out in the public.
And he was treated
to a very special performance.
Take a look at this.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-That's real. That is real.
That's -- That's -- [ Laughs ]
That's his reaction, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's the treat
for the pope.
Right after that,
he asked for a gong.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Oh, oh."
[ Gong clangs ]
Now, the pope's
New Year's resolution is
to say no to more stuff.
[ Laughter ]
For this, as a result,
the pope was just given
a new job.
Look at this.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-He didn't like it.
He didn't like it.
-It's what he's there for.
-Cracking -- Cracking walnuts.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this BMW car?
They just unveiled a new SUV
that can actually change colors.
Real. Watch this.
Ooh. It's real.
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Oh.
-Wow.
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Yeah, yeah, experts say
it's gonna revolutionize
the way you forget
where you parked your car.
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, are we driving
a white SUV, or..."
[ Laughter ]
Now, police are gonna be like,
"In pursuit of a black --
wait, silver --
no, wait -- a red --
Damn it!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this.
So, Kohler just unveiled
its new stillness bath
that emits fog
to replicate a spa experience.
Look at this thing.
Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
To make it even more spa-like,
the bath also emits a hologram
of a naked old guy
who's just two feet away
from you.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Taco Bell just
launched a subscription service
that sends customers a taco
every day for a month.
-Oh!
-Well, it looks like
we're about to go through
another toilet paper shortage.
We have a great show.